shipping delays worker protests and
massive political pressure to pull out
of China this is the frustrating reality
for Apple which has had so many problems
with its manufacturing that their CEO
Tim Cook is now getting publicly
accosted by reporters do you think it's
problematic to do business with the
Communist Chinese party when they
suppress human rights China's
manufacturing capabilities have been
have the largest companies but that same
manufacturing strength has now turned
into a cancerous dependency and it's put
Apple into an impossible situation to
understand why Apple has become
completely dependent on Chinese
manufacturing we have to ask the
following question what made China so
appealing to Apple Executives in the
first place
in the 1990s Apple manufactured most of
their products in the United States that
changed when Tim Cook joined the company
cook started at Apple in March of 1998
as a senior vice president for worldwide
operations right off the bat Steve Jobs
needed him to solve an important problem
Apple was just about to launch the first
iMac it was the first big release for
Apple since Steve Jobs had returned to
the company after 11 years away he was
confident it would be a hit so he needed
assurance that Apple could fulfill
hundreds of thousands of holiday orders
Tim Cook's solution was to call up Air
Freight suppliers and pre-purchase a
hundred million dollars worth of
shipments in advance this was a huge
gamble if the iMac launch went poorly
Apple would lose tons of money on these
prepaid shipping fees Tim Cook certainly
wouldn't be the CEO today Steve Jobs
probably would have fired him and Cook's
bet paid off in a big way the iMac was a
huge success and apple was one of the
only computer manufacturers that could
fulfill every order of that holiday
season this early move made Tim Cook a
hero in the eyes of Steve Jobs after
years of struggling to scale Supply
chains Apple finally had someone with
the competence and risk appetite to
really grow the business cook developed
a reputation for ruthlessness calling
inventory fundamentally evil and working
tirelessly to squeeze more and more
efficiency out of Apple's supply chain
for years cook optimized Apple's
domestic operations but over time things
changed for one thing products got
smaller and required more specialized
manufacturing the other thing which cook
quickly realized is that Apple was
starting to pull away from its Rivals
when he joined the company only about
three percent of people used Apple
products but the iPod was a runaway
success selling tens of millions of
units every year Apple needed to press
home this Advantage it had built up but
to do that it needed to massively scale
up its Supply chains that's when China
came into the picture
[Music]
thank you for coming we're going to make
some history together today is the 2007
Australian Open champion
what
we are calling it iPhone the first woman
speaker in our history Nancy Pelosi
I ingested my ancestor yes
the iPhone was just about to be released
in stores and Steve Jobs noticed a big
problem he had been carrying a prototype
iPhone in his pocket and the screen was
getting scratched so we called a meeting
he took his phone out of his pocket and
then he pulled out his keys this was
going to be a normal user experience he
pointed out everyone was going to be
carrying their phone with their keys so
the screen couldn't be made of plastic
jobs told his Executives that he
wouldn't sell a product that got easily
scratched he wanted a glass screen and
he wanted it perfect in six weeks I
can't it was a Herculean task one which
most supply chain experts thought would
be impossible but companies like apple
thrive on achieving the impossible so an
apple executive booked a flight to
Shenzhen and told the plant to start
working the factory immediately directed
8 000 workers to replace the screens
they worked 12 hour shifts to get it
done but within a few days the plant was
producing over 10 000 iPhones with glass
screens per day that hard work was worth
it helped by China's manufacturing
capacity the iPhone went on to become
become the best selling product in
history this ability to mobilize massive
amounts of human labor is what makes
China so important to Apple and
thousands of other companies wages in
China are much lower than in America but
the equation that companies like apple
must solve when considering where to
manufacture their products is much more
complicated
Manufacturing in China isn't always a
good decision for American companies
lots of inexperienced entrepreneurs have
been burned by shoddy Chinese
manufacturers who over promise and then
under deliver people often joke about
Chinese manufacturers offering what's
called a 50 50 partnership where the
American company loses half their money
in the first year and then the other
half in the second year how does this
keep happening time and time again the
answer is that Chinese manufacturers
have a playbook for tricking American
companies into over committing it goes
something like this let's say you're
running a company that makes coffee cups
you've been manufacturing them in
America but you simply can't keep up
with the competition anymore it seems
like every other brand is able to slash
their prices and still make a decent
profit margin so you start looking at
cheaper manufacturing options China is
an obvious choice since so many
companies make products there so you
visit a manufacturer and the product
sample looks amazing they've been able
to perfectly match what you've been
making in America plus they're willing
to do it at a fraction of the cost it
sounds perfect so you sign up place a
purchase order and start shipping the
products to your customers no one can
tell the difference and you're starting
to make a healthy profit margin again
but this is where things take a turn for
the worse see your Chinese manufacturer
needs to make a profit for themselves
and the price they originally quoted you
was too good to be true they can't raise
their prices because you might take your
business somewhere else so they start
looking for other ways to squeeze out a
profit they might switch to using
cheaper materials the plastic in that
coffee cup might now contain toxic
chemicals and in some cases they will
actually make subtle changes in the
product design you might have specified
that the walls of the coffee cup lid
need to be at least one millimeter thick
but over time the manufacturer will send
you thinner and thinner coffee cups to
save money on raw materials this process
is called quality fade it allows the
manufacturer to increase their margins
all without raising prices or even
telling the customer what's happening
it's a huge problem because companies
usually don't have quality control
systems in place to prevent this from
happening if you aren't already testing
your products for toxic chemicals and
the manufacturer starts secretly
switching materials on you you might not
find out for years this quality fade
strategy works well for Chinese
manufacturers who work with smaller
businesses the products slowly get worse
over time and as long as no one notices
the manufacturers can book the profits
but the quality fade strategy could
never work with Apple
the iPhone is simply too complex to
secretly start switching out components
and apple Engineers have a rigorous set
of quality assurance practices in place
if Apple's manufacturers wanted to
maximize their profits they'd have to
come up with a more subtle workaround
the solution they found is one I call
morality fade and it's nearly impossible
for Apple to detect see while Apple can
easily test their iPhones to make sure
that they were made with the right
materials and to the right
specifications it's much harder to
verify that they've been made to the
same human rights standards if a
manufacturer has a fixed price contract
with Apple and they want to increase
their profit margins the only option is
to reduce their labor costs and the
easiest way to reduce labor costs is to
use workers you can exploit seven Apple
supplies in China are using forced labor
from Shenzhen they participate in
state-run programs the same ones that
are allegedly part of China's campaign
of genocide against the uyghurs
uyghurs are the dominant ethnic group in
xinjiang unlike every other region of
China where most inhabitants are Han
Chinese uyghurs have their own distinct
culture most practice Islam and they had
a historically strong Independence
Movement for years under the banner of
fighting terrorism the Chinese Communist
party has been forcing uyghurs to work
in factories we see workers every 50 of
them are watched by one minder they're
surveilled online and in person they
have to attend these Mandarin studies
after work and political indoctrination
sessions and these factories have Butler
fences one of those factories was a
Foxconn facility which manufactures up
to half of all the world's iPhones some
companies are directly using uighur
laborer to manufacture their products
and other companies you know in the long
complicated supply chain and they might
not know it's one of the clearest
examples of the morality fade strategy
there are undoubtedly others which just
haven't seen the light of day and it's a
huge problem for apple and Tim Cook
apple has a playbook for addressing
negative stories about the conditions
inside the factories that manufacture
iPhones Apple's CEOs
is very troubled by the string of
sukon Apple has been championing itself
as a perfect Enterprise but it is all a
facade they categorically denounce the
situation and make plans to audit their
supply chain to prevent this in the
future Apple does one of the best jobs
of any companies in our industry of
understanding the working conditions in
our supply chain we go into these
suppliers and we go into their secondary
and tertiary suppliers
places where nobody's ever gone before
and audited them before and we're pretty
rigorous about it it's crisis
Communications 101 and that strategy has
worked for the most part Apple really
does want to avoid major public
relations backlash so they constantly
push their suppliers to follow Chinese
labor laws and avoid taking shortcuts to
save money faced with the morality fade
scenario I just described the obvious
solution for Apple would be to pull out
of China but it's easier said than done
Apple hasn't really outsourced
production to China in the traditional
sense instead they've built one of the
deepest cross-border relationships in
business history throughout the iPhone
era Apple has embedded top product
designers and Manufacturing Engineers
directly into their suppliers facilities
these are Apple employees but they will
often live in China for months at a time
to make sure that new production
processes get designed properly in a
typical manufacturing relationship the
designer will often hand off a product
to a manufacturer and let them figure
out how to actually produce it at scale
Apple takes a completely different
approach working much more closely with
its manufacturing Partners they've spent
billions of dollars on custom machinery
and developed Cutting Edge expertise
that sets them apart from the
competition and why have they gone to
all this trouble because of the iPhone
itself this is a deconstructed iPhone 4S
to show you how intricate the internal
components are the iPhone 4 was
assembled by Foxconn and pegatron
another Taiwanese electronics company it
sold 4 million units in its first three
days on the market and more than 60
million over its lifetime remember the
iPhone 4 was released in October of
2011. at this point it's almost 12 years
old and it's only gotten more complex
the point is that assembling the iPhone
has never been easy every generation has
been made with the latest technology in
both software and Hardware China didn't
have the capabilities to scale up iPhone
production before Apple showed up Tim
Cook and the Apple team brought those
skills and helped build up the
competency over many years as a result
they turned the iPhone into the most
profitable and best-selling product in
history the best-selling car of all time
is the Toyota Corolla with 50 million
Vehicles delivered the best-selling toy
of all time is the Rubik's Cube at 400
million units sold the best-selling book
series is Harry Potter with 500 million
copies sold the iPhone has sold more
than 2 billion units it's not just the
best-selling mobile phone it's also the
best-selling music player the
best-selling camera and the best-selling
computer of all time the iPhone was only
possible because of China but even
though China made Apple the biggest
company in the world it now poses a
massive risk apple is completely reliant
on China more than 95 percent of iPhones
airpods Macs and iPods are made there
and China makes up nearly one-fifth of
the company's revenues this dependency
means that as tensions escalate between
Beijing and Washington Apple is caught
in a tough Place Apple wasn't the first
computer company to embrace the Chinese
manufacturing opportunity both
Hewlett-Packard and compact made PCS
there throughout the 1990s but Apple
took a very different approach from
these earlier companies if you look at
the parts of an iPhone you'll notice
that nearly everything is custom made
this allows Apple to regularly deliver
new features at every major keynote but
the trade-off is that it requires a much
deeper integration with the Chinese
supply chain instead of handing over
specifications to suppliers and letting
them decide how to build devices Apple
would buy the relevant equipment and
install it in the factory themselves
they were so dedicated to scaling the
production of the iPhone that by 2012
they had over 7 billion dollars of
Assets in China to put that into
perspective Apple's Machinery in China
became more valuable than all of Apple's
buildings and retail stores combined no
other tech company was pursuing this
strategy but Tim Cook realized that
these huge investments in physical
equipment could unlock new opportunities
now what's interesting about cook though
isn't just that he had the confidence to
throw money at a problem when the time
was right it's also that he had
instituted an extremely rigorous process
for vetting suppliers Apple Engineers
were constantly dispatched to meet with
Chinese suppliers in person and while
they were on site they would drill the
CEO with technical questions until they
could no longer get answers then they
would move deeper and deeper into the
organization until they were talking to
the most technical people at the
supplier to understand their full
capabilities Apple would only move
forward with a contract if the company's
engineer signed off on the suppliers
organization it was an exhausting
process for anyone bidding for Apple's
business but landing a contract could be
completely trained transformative Not
only would the supplier's revenues
immediately start tracking with Apple's
growth trajectory but Apple Engineers
would effectively take over the research
and development roadmap to make sure
that the supplier was hitting key
Milestones just look at how Apple
completely transformed Foxconn in the
year 2000 Foxconn started making IMAX
for Apple they did a total of three
billion dollars in Revenue that year Ten
Years Later Foxconn had grown to nearly
100 billion dollars in Revenue more than
its five biggest competitors combined
the Chinese government was quick to
realize how important the Apple
relationship would be for economic
development after the 2008 Global
financial crisis Beijing issued over one
trillion dollars in loans and over half
of that money went toward infrastructure
spending this meant bigger apartment
buildings to house millions of Migrant
laborers as well as more reliable
highways airports and warehouses China
was betting that Apple would continue to
dominate the global Electronics Market
in 2010 they released both the iPhone 4
and the first iPad great reviews and
just as Tim Cook had bet big on the
success of the iMac in 1998 the founder
of Foxconn a guy named Terry guo was
ready to double down on Apple he met
with Tim Cook to plan the launch of that
Year's products and argued that Apple
was massively underestimating demand he
could tell that the combination of the
iPhone 4 and the iPad were going to mark
an inflection point for apple and they
needed to scale up it was an easy pitch
to cook since Foxconn was going to foot
the bill for the new facilities that
sounds like great news for Apple but
it's also a huge headache how many tool
and die makers do you know in the US now
we could have I could call a meeting
around the United States and say what
every tool and die maker come to this
room tonight
we wouldn't fill the road in China you
would need several cities China is no
longer the best option for Apple it's
become the only option
[Applause]
so what's the solution can apple
actually pull out of China right now the
answer is no in 2019 Tim Cook stood next
to Donald Trump at a manufacturing
facility in Austin Texas the goal of the
photo op was to let the world know that
Apple was committed to making products
in the United States again it was a
win-win for both of them Trump could say
that he was bringing back manufacturing
jobs while Tim Cook could say that he
was getting ahead of the China issue but
that event was mostly smoke and mirrors
the facility had actually been in
operation since 2013. it didn't
represent any real shift in Apple's
manufacturing strategy back in 2012
Steve Jobs was very direct with Barack
Obama about Apple's manufacturing plans
he told him Point Blank that those jobs
aren't coming back that might have been
a reasonable economic decision to make
back then further globalization looked
inevitable but things have gotten so
much more complicated since then covid
lockdowns wreaked havoc at Foxconn and
created a shortage of 6 million iPhones
this last holiday period but shipping
delays are much more tall tolerable than
human rights abuses and when Factory
workers started protesting the
restrictions Apple's response was
telling in the past Apple had generally
been supportive of improving working
conditions in Chinese factories but not
this time instead of supporting the
protesters or issuing a statement about
the importance of free speech and
democracy Apple started restricting the
use of airdrop to share information
about protests this led to harsh
criticism from American politicians on
both sides of the aisle on the left you
had Senator Mark Warner saying that
Apple was quote doing the bidding of the
Chinese Communist party and on the right
you had Senator Josh Hawley saying quote
when the Communists in Beijing tell
Apple to jump it asks how high it's
always dangerous to be in a position
where you have no allies in Washington
Democrats and Republicans don't agree on
much but right now they both agree that
Apple needs to pull out of China so
could Apple actually do it where could
they go
India would certainly be a logical
Choice it's a democracy of more than a
billion people and English is officially
the second language there are far fewer
geopolitical risks and Indians are
starting to buy more and more iPhones
each year as incomes rise the country is
accelerating and Manufacturing as well
in 2014 Indio is responsible for just
two percent of global smartphone
production but that grew to 16 in 2022.
you have political situation especially
between China and U.S it is a great
opportunity for us Samsung has been able
to build 120 million phones annually in
India and the government is dedicated to
improving infrastructure Apple has
actually been manufacturing iPhones in
India since 2017 but that headline is a
little bit misleading the vast majority
of the Apple supply chain is still in
China and even though India is starting
to produce smartphones in large volumes
they are still years behind The Cutting
Edge of the 20 million phones made in
India last year most were budget phones
that sell for 250 or less the country
just isn't ready to start manufacturing
flagship iPhones yeah India does have
over a billion people but they don't
have the skilled technicians and migrant
laborers who are critical to iPhone
production the infrastructure is still
years behind too which makes
Transportation utilities and
communication networks all more
difficult so not India well what about
Vietnam Vietnam has truly become one of
the great miracles of the world after
all the average Vietnamese worker earns
half as much as their counterparts in
China so there are significant labor
cost savings Apple has been pushing hard
to make Vietnam work it's planning to
make more than 50 percent of airpods
there by 2025 but it's unlikely that the
numbers will ever really add up by some
counts China has more Factory workers
than Vietnam has people so much of
hitting the ruthless iPhone production
schedule revolves around hiring tons of
people and quickly ramping up
manufacturing China's migrant workers
are critical to this effort and there
are nearly 300 million of them Vietnam
by comparison has fewer than 100 million
residents in total decoupling from China
will be a massive task for Apple they've
invested so much into the country and
it's impossible to just pick up and
leave in 2016 Tim Cook personally signed
a five-year agreement to spend more than
275 billion dollars in China instead of
preparing for an exit apple is doubling
down on China and moving even deeper
into the country the end result is that
Apple isn't really looking at an
alternative manufacturing center at best
they're pursuing a China plus one
strategy where they will add additional
capacity elsewhere without pulling back
in China whatsoever Apple will probably
just wait until the media attention dies
down and then keep investing but this
story is far from over in order to
understand how the U.S China
relationship will evolve over the coming
years it's important to learn the
history of China's leader Xi Jinping if
you want to know everything about his
rise to power just watch this video next
thanks a lot